we saw the time magazine did a cover
story on colin kaepernick we are
wondering earlier this morning if Time
magazine would consider Colin camera
Kaepernick for the man of the year and
then all of a sudden we realized that
he's on the cover of Time magazine and
sean gregory is the person who profiled
colin kaepernick a senior writer for
Time magazine Sean thanks for joining us
how did this come about thank you Dan um
the movement has just spread the acts of
peaceful protest kneeling during the
anthem we've seen it across sport you
know spread throughout the NFL Megan
Rapinoe and soccer and high school teams
college teams middle school teams high
school volleyball teams so company he he
definitely sparked sparked an action of
the sort that we haven't seen in sports
in society you know maybe since like the
1960s did you talk to Kaepernick so we
did not we you know we we hope to and
he's you know choosing to I guess let
his actions you know speak for itself
for themselves so no we did not but the
stories more it's talking to a lot of
different people about their reaction to
this we Sui you know we spoke to nate
Boyer for example who's a green beret
who met with Kaepernick and make great
points about how he might disagree with
the method uh you know of kneeling
during the flag but he respects
Kaepernick's right to do that and he
fought he fought for Cap'n X
Kaepernick's right to do that and he
appreciates that he's taking advantage
of of what he's he's fought for you know
we spoke to Jim Brown you know civil
rights activist was right beside
Muhammad Ali back in the 60 supported
him and and Jim Brown said of course he
supports what Kaepernick is saying that
the ex traditional shooting of unarmed
black man has to stop but he he doesn't
eat disagrees with the method you know
and doesn't think you should challenge
the flag so I think the nice part about
where this debate has evolved I think
when Kaepernick first
there was so much anger and then he
evolved he met with Boyer they decide
you know kneeling might be a more
reverential respectful gesture now
you're seeing everybody meal and then
when you talk to folks you know you know
so the high school players we talked to
they make the point that when like a
player gets hurt you kneel right so it's
a sign of respect and reverence so um
maybe and what what kenny stills from
amsa maybe we shouldn't be calling this
a protest it's more just kind of raising
awareness of what's going on well even
Tebow telling me took a news well yeah
exactly exactly um the what kind of
reaction you think there's gonna be
negative reaction to discover story I
don't think yeah you know I yes
definitely I think for some people did
the site of Colin Kaepernick Kaepernick
at the cover on the cover might say you
know oh my gosh he does he's doing this
for attention oh now he got what he
strive for and I don't think that's
right i mean you got to remember
Kaepernick didn't go out of his way to
advertise that he was doing this it was
just somebody noticed you know and then
if Steve why from nfl.com notice and
asked him about it and so you know yes
and this the reason I think they'll be
negative reaction sadly it's just a
negative reaction that some some folks
have gotten for kneeling for example
this middle school team in Texas but
your kids took a knee and they got death
threats online no terrible in a racist
name-calling and all this stuff and
that's just it's really sad to see that
and it makes it makes the point that
Kaepernick Kaepernick is protesting
clear right it makes his point for him
that thing's you know aren't great and
and you see that went by the reaction to
what he's doing and what other people
are doing and I wonder what's next Sean
with the athletes or this protest or but
what is how did they take it to another
level or do they that's a good that's a
great question and you know we spoke to
Chris Paul on this and even he you know
he said listen yeah i know the symbolism
is great but we got to act we got to get
going and there's to school you know one
school of thought on this is it's not up
to the athletes right i mean they're not
politicians they're not policymakers
they can get people talking and then let
the professionals take over but you know
i think some athletes are taking steps
Malcolm victims from the
goals is set up either this week next
week or the week after our ride along
with Philadelphia Police Harry Edwards
the sociologist who spoke to be and
helped organize the Black Power salute
in 1968 and spoke to the Seahawks about
these issues he's encouraging you know
barbershop talks so you know maybe the
first step is is awareness and then
dialogue and you know and ultimately you
know improvements in police community
relations you know the people the folks
on the ground that that's a complicated
problem it's hard to solve but I think
the athletes are aware that you know you
have to start doing more than protesting
or you know these see signs of
disagreement and whether these signs of
disagreement are going to continue its
really interesting you know Victor
Oladipo of the Thunder said you know he
expects this to happen in the end for
some folks in the NBA to do the same
thing so now as the NBA season starts
it'll be interesting to see it to see if
it carries on because remember at the
ESPYs LeBron and Chris Paul and Carmelo
and Dwyane Wade kind of made a strong
statement you know stepped out of the
comfort zone that athletes have
traditionally been in over the last 20
years where you don't engage on these
issues we're seeing a total reversal of
that Sean thanks for joining us and good
luck with the cover story great thank
you Dad sean gregory time magazine the
Dan Patrick show weekday mornings on
audience